Après ma vidéo sur les vieux et la technologie,
j’ai eu plein de vieux qui m’ont fait :
Bien vue la vidéo !
Traduction :
Va bien te faire enc**** fils de p*** !
Et je me suis dit qu’en fait les jeunes et la technologie,
c’est bien con aussi...
Ahhhh ! ben si !
D’ailleurs, ça commence super tôt,
les gamins veulent tous un téléphone portable
et l’argument imbattable qu’on sort
pour en avoir un c’est :
Et ben comme ça, je pourrais t’appeler
si je termine plus tôt, ou si j’ai un problème...
Bon d’accord
t’as gagné !
Yeees !
(Dans sa tête)
A moi Candy Crush, Snapchat, Instagram !
Tiens. Tu feras attention,
c’est mon premier téléphone portable hein.
Je crois que le jeune et le téléphone portable,
c’est devenu indissociable aujourd’hui.
Moi, tu m’enlèves mon téléphone
je suis en panique hein.
Il est où bordel ! Où tu l’as mis ?
Tu l’as mis où ?
D’ailleurs, parfois,
je me fais des petits coups de stress :
Attends,
mais il est où mon téléphone ?
T’es en train de chercher ton téléphone dans la poche
alors que tu l’as dans la main.
Ah ouais, merde,
putain j'suis con !
Bah ouais t’es con !
Hey, il est en train de chercher son téléphone
dans la poche alors qu’il l’a dans la main !
Regardez moi ce con !
Nan, c’est pas vrai...
Y’a un autre truc qui me stresse
avec les téléphones :
J’ai pris une photo marrante.
Je sais pas pourquoi,
quand je vois un téléphone qui a 1% de batterie
ça me met dans un état de stress et de panique total !
Tu veux pas recharger ?
Bah au pire
j’ai plus de batterie, il s’éteint,
je me fais renverser,
je tombe dans le ravin,
je peux pas appeler les secours,
je décède.
Et tu peux plus jouer à Candy Crush
non plus..
Je vais recharger alors ?
Ouais
Et parfois, y’a qu’un seul chargeur
pour deux téléphones, alors là…
Il parait que t’as un chargeur ?
Ah nan, mais j’en ai qu’un et
puis il faut que je charge mon téléphone !
Il te reste combien de % ?
(Musique de western)
6% !
5%!
Maintenant, je peux plus
passer une seule seconde sans rien faire,
dès que je m’ennuie
je sors mon téléphone.
Par exemple, je suis dans un bar avec un pote et
qu’il va aux toilettes,
je n’peux pas m’empêcher
de prendre mon téléphone.
Qu’est-ce que tu fais là,
je suis toujours là,
sympa le mec qui prend son téléphone
alors qu’il est avec son pote !
Tu veux pas aller aux chiottes
comme ça je vais sur facebook ?
Ouais, bonne idée ouais, allez !
Nan pas comme ça..
Alors, les plus touchés,
ce sont les ados bien évidemment
qui développent des symptômes bizarres
à cause des téléphones,
par exemple, ma petite sœur est touchée
par ce que j’appelle le syndrome Snapchat,
c’est-à-dire,
on est à table avec mes parents et
et comme toutes les ados, elle est sur son téléphone
et elle tire la gueule quand tout à coup…
(Déclics appareil photo)
Ah oui, l’accessoire obligatoire chez les jeunes,
ce sont les écouteurs.
Je ne peux pas sortir seul
sans mes écouteurs !
Oh putain, j’ai oublié !
J’ai l’impression d’avoir oublié
autre chose…
Après, je peux comprendre que certains
soient dépassés par la technologie,
ça évolue tellement vite.
Y’a une nouvelle application qui s’appelle Yo
et qui permet d’envoyer à tous ces amis des Yo.
Cette application est valorisée
à plus d’un million de dollars.
Patron, c’est une nouvelle application
qui permet d’envoyer Yo à tous ses amis.
C’est tout?
Oui.
J’achète, un million de dollars !
Je m’en occupe
Patron y’a une application qui vient d’être lancée,
elle s’appelle Wesh, c’est pour envoyer des Wesh.
Eeeuuuuuhhhhh…
Aujourd’hui, les jeunes,
ils peuvent se contacter avec n’importe quoi,
avec les SMS, avec Facebook,
avec Whatsapp, avec... Yo
et si y’a bien un truc de jeune,
c’est le fait d’envoyer un message à quelqu’un
qui est dans la même maison, ou appartement que toi.
Ca arrive !
Putain, t’es où Cyprien ?!
Allô allô Cyprien ?
Je suis là, hein.
Ah, t’es là toi !
Ca fait 15 minutes.
Bah ouais,
tu pourrais répondre quand même, t’es mignon toi.
En même temps, on a grandi avec la technologie,
avec les téléphones, avec Internet,
c’est ça la différence avec les vieux.
Nous n’avons pas les mêmes habitudes.
Un vieux qui appelle un taxi :
Taxi !
Un jeune qui appelle un taxi :
Un vieux qui commande à manger :
Oui, c’est pour commander
une pizza s’il vous plait.
Un jeune qui commande à manger :
Un vieux qui fait l’amour :
Un jeune qui fait l’amour :
T’aimes ça hein, cochonne.
Après, y’a jeune et jeune.
Je l’avoue, moi-même,
j’ai grandi avec des trucs qui ne sont pas les mêmes
que ceux des jeunes d’aujourd’hui
et ça fait mal.
Oh putain,
Super Mario Bros !
Enzo, est-ce que tu veux qu’on joue
à mon premier jeu-vidéo ?
Grave, mon tout premier jeu
c’est Watch Dogs mais il est pas très beau hein,
il pique un peu les yeux.
C’est quoi ton jeu ?
Nan mais c’est…
moi aussi, mon premier jeu,
c’est Watch Dogs donc si…
si t’as déjà joué c’est…
laisse tomber, c'est pas grave.
Mais peut-être que
je suis plus jeune alors ?
Je m’en bats les steaks !
Tchao !
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle.